[Music]
over 40 years later and Greece is still
the word feels like we've given a gift
to mankind somehow you know around the
world only et has these
behind-the-scenes stories from the
beloved classic oh god it was so hot
people of thinking they had brought up
the Linda Ronstadt they'd brought up
Marie Osmond and I said they're
wonderful but every guy in the world
wants Olivia and jhanas right and I knew
that because I wanted and every girl
wants to be like her and I said if you
don't see this you guys are nuts
because there was only one person in the
world that was sandy and that was a
living in John
John said that the pain ratio of numbers
that definitely the dance contest and
the gym was the hardest oh god I'm so
hot people were thinking the problem was
a lot of work was done it was really hot
it was really hot in that gym but it was
uh we had a ball I'm in the home movie
for me it was like going to high school
I never went to high school like that
school dropout no graduation I mean I
have to admit Frankie but it was so
wonderful I mean he he's just it's got
something and I guess being in the
character Frenchy and wishing for a
guardian angel to tell me what to do and
to get me out of this terrible Jam you
know that those were two days that I'll
never forget
well I remember the first time he got
close to me I mean drool just came and
he told me that all the hits that he's
had he had major major hits you this
school dropout is his most popular song
requested everywhere like his lieutenant
like a second you know yeah so
I thought that you could maybe be my
second at Thunder Road
well scene where John and I where I
asked him to be my second at Thunder
Road and that was my concept for that
scene because the the scene was there
and but it just didn't have a hook there
wasn't like it wasn't working you know
for me anyway and and I thought well how
do you express that how the guys express
love for each other you know and after
this kind of vulnerable scene of one
tough guy asking another guy could you
could you back me up okay so I get into
trouble and then they were close friends
and hell they hug hug you mean they hug
you what are you gonna do Eve you're
hugging for the guys are there in the
50s yeah you know it didn't work that's
all well how we get out of that I
thought okay well they just kind of get
away from each other
oh the hitting star that's what happened
to the hug you know that kind of love
puppy love kind of thing turned into the
hug and then oh my god what are we doing
without the cone baby get cool
[Music]
tell me about it
step I always think of the minute that I
came out as sandy - as being kind of
exciting even on the day we did it all
that was just I was a natural reaction
it's so much fun to see her dressed up
in that garb you know that number like
doing that number was great fun when
Olivia tried on her sandy outfit you
know the Sandy's hot mama sandy outfit
we were on location doing the driving
and it was nighttime and nobody
recognized her she had her hair all done
up in the tight pants and nobody really
nice to her this is the jacket I've
maintained we won't talk about the pants
I just got nothing has been able to
replace it conceptually you know you can
name other kind of movies or musicals
that have replaced themselves over the
years but this one you can't quite
pinpoint maybe it's the commenting on
every one like this high school and calm
and everyone kind of loved the birth of
rock and roll right and that exemplifies
that no its interpretive on this you
know it was different than every other
thing I've worked on in 37 years it was
a party it really was and everybody was
getting a chance to live out some
fantasy that they'd had of the 50s I
think it's just amazing to be in a movie
that's a classic I mean it's being
popular seems like every year from then
I've heard someone talk about grease how
they love and all the children love it
or their grandchildren love it and they
watch it on tape at least once a week
it's just incredible feel very lucky
feels like we've given a gift to mankind
somehow you know around the world and
that feels so it's so honorable I think
don't you mm-hmm
it feels like you've contributed
something and somebody's glad you're
alive and we're still alive
[Music]